[Music]
if your school had a piano
chances are you've heard this piece at
least once
beethoven's fur elise has become the
go-to classical piano piece for young
students
do you have a uh like a favorite piece
or or song to play on the piano yes
for at least oh that's your favorite
that's your favorite one
it's also been programmed into music
boxes played on wine glasses
and used for garbage trucks in taiwan
it's made appearances in movies such as
harry potter
django unchained and a charlie brown
christmas
it's one of the few classical piano
pieces that most people would recognize
by name
yet when played at series piano recitals
it's often met with giggles and
confusion
according to pianist igor levitt it's
one of beethoven's most recognizable
melodies
but the first person who published it
wrote that it was graceful
but not exactly important the piece was
of course written for someone named
elise
but who was elise so why is fury lease
so famous
and more importantly does it deserve its
popularity
or is it overrated
okay well here's the deal here's the
deal i think i'm actually in favor of
the tune
i really like the song oh no yeah i was
like in seventh grade i think
nas came out with a song called i can
it was like a little sample you know
what i'm saying i was just like oh this
is this is this old beethoven tune
i can learn this
[Music]
so i'm a fan of the song i'm sorry i
know you're
no no i am being a little facetious
about how much i dislike it
but that being said i do not love it
before we get into whether or not fury
lease is overrated
let's dive into the history and mystery
surrounding beethoven's most famous
piece
despite verlise's popularity today it
wasn't published until 1867
40 years after beethoven's death the
musicologist ludwig nol
founded with the possessions of one of
beethoven's friends teresa malfati
but noel didn't think much about the
piece as mentioned earlier he wrote that
it was
not exactly important and it's possible
that beethoven would have agreed
in 1822 he considered publishing it in a
set of easy piano pieces
but he decided not to even though the
publisher didn't think the piece was
important
the greater public disagreed the piece
quickly grew in popularity
it was published again several times in
1870.
in 1900 just 33 years after its first
publication tonger
published fear elise in a collection of
the most popular classical and romantic
piano pieces
development in the recording technology
of the early 1900s
allowed the piece to be heard by
mainstream audiences and even played in
movies
in the 1940s at least three movies
included fury lease in their soundtracks
in 1965 fear elise aired on a charlie
brown christmas
and so a hundred years after his
discovery fear elise's rise into popular
culture
was cemented so how did furless become
so famous
part of the popularity probably comes
from the stardom of beethoven
he's influenced generations of composers
and artists throughout the 18
and 1900s even still today of course
and one can get a sense of his legendary
status as symbolized in this
zeus-like sculpture from 1902.
the mystery surrounding the title also
adds to the appeal of the peace
fear elise translates to four elise
so who is elise scholars have been
fascinated by this question
and they've proposed many different
theories is it terese malfati
she had possession of the peace at the
time of this discovery in addition
beethoven was once wildly in love with
her but her name isn't
elise or is it elizabeth raquel
she was a close friend of beethoven but
then how did teresa gain possession of
the peace
or was it another elise entirely like
the child prodigy
elise behrensfeld she lived across the
street from teresa malfati
these theories have appeared in
newspapers magazines
and even documentaries but the identity
of elise
remains unsolved and while it's unclear
whether elise was one of beethoven's
love interests
popular culture has picked up on the
idea the comments of youtube recordings
are full of jokes like
maybe if elise hadn't rejected him i
would have been able to play this
at the time fairlease was discovered in
the 1860s there was an
increase in demand for relatively easy
piano music
this was due to a growth in a wealthy
middle class and advancements in piano
design
that drastically increased piano
ownership in europe
pianos became smaller and more
affordable so they were accessible to
more people
now let's dive into the music of your
release to see what specifically may
have contributed to its popularity
for one the opening sounds rather
complicated
yet it's still very approachable for
piano students
[Music]
why do you think the song theory elise
is so popular
because it's a little bit complicated
nothing can be too fun if it's not
if it's not complicated enough
a little bit of challenge in there yeah
uh miss emily
um why do you decide to teach a few
elise to your students
um i've been teaching piano for about 20
years now and i realized that the first
section
of for release is actually pretty
achievable
to most intermediate students and what's
interesting is i think that
the tune that so many people have heard
that the kids really feel like
now i've arrived as a piano player
you know i'm not playing those songs
that are just in the lesson books this
is like a real song by a real composer
another reason why fur elise may be so
popular
is because its structure is very similar
to many pop songs
pop songs often use a verse chorus
bridge structure
fair elise uses a similar structure
called the rondo form
the rondo form typically consists of a
main theme
alternating with supporting themes and
sections
here is theme a of furlies
[Music]
theme b
[Music]
and theme c
notice how the verse course bridge form
and the rondo form
are nearly identical the overall effect
is that the a theme is repeated enough
times that the listener can recall the
tune
after listening to it once it's kind of
catchy
[Music]
we've mapped out furlese's rise in fame
but does it really deserve its
popularity
let's consider what a furley's
enthusiast and a furlish critic
might have to say about the piece let's
first talk about the melody
definitely singable definitely
lovely and memorable but does it
have a profound quality not really it's
very
casual it's sing-songy i just think that
it lacks
in the emotional depth of the melody
itself
combined with the harmony
and it doesn't hold this tension that i
think a lot of great melodies do
for example beethoven's second movement
from his pathetique sonata
[Music]
there's so much tension there it's very
delicate
because each chord change
makes you hold your breath and i i feel
i feel like i can breathe very easily
during birthdays
i do think it's catchier than many of
his other bag of towels but
it's hard to say that catchiness can be
a mer unto itself
because think of nursery rhymes for
example
they're great of course they're
memorable they're catchy
but is humpty dumpty the most
profound thing ever popular doesn't mean
it's good but
i think it has it is popular because
there are some merits in
these things like this repetition i
think so yes it is
miniature and uh seems kind of like
there's no finality to it but i think
that's a feature and not a bug as they
say
uh of of this piece it's also great
because it repeats forever it's like
background music for
like a video game or something you know
you could almost you would maybe get
tired of it but i think most people
they could hear that on repeat for a
long time and kind of just settles in
the background and it gives a sort of
comfort to it you're almost changing my
mind about furlese but i would add
one thing i think the melody is not
quite as melancholic
nor tragic nor as longing as people give
it credit for
i think one of the most beautiful thing
actually is in the main theme when he
goes to c major right you
sorry i'm skipping a lot of those and
then
get back you know he tries to go to it's
to go c major
brighter um you know we know when
beethoven writes c major it's like
very very heroic um bright kind of thing
and he tries to go there
but he just sequences back down into a
minor i think there's something
beautiful about that the last question
that i really wanted to ask you
is that if you had a student beginner to
intermediate level that
was looking to learn a new piece would
you
and have you ever assigned for release
before it was requested
uh i have not assigned for elise before
it's requested
i could definitely see myself assigning
it depending on the student but no i
have not assigned it
ever joseph just cut that we that's all
we need we can clip that
that's all that matters and we can use
it
just kidding since fury leaks isn't as
important as some of beethoven's other
works
it seems strange that it became so
popular but
this is a common trend in music for
example johann pacobel
helped develop the feud and the chorale
prelude during the baroque period yet
several hundred years after his death
taco bell's canon became his most
popular work
the piece itself is not that musically
complex
it includes a cello line that repeats
the same eight notes for five minutes
straight
[Music]
today you can hear furlyse in almost
every part of the globe from
ice cream trucks to tv shows it's even
gone commercial and featured in many
advertisements
cannot give any to my dumb brother
hands off their miner your elise
continues to inspire musicians today
the legend enio moriconi remixed fury
elise into a western score
that opens the film in glorious bastards
listen for how the music communicates
tension
by contrasting fury lisa's simple melody
line with a dramatic
guitar part
[Music]
you can see how today's artists use the
familiarity of fury lease to communicate
complex emotions and ideas
this leads us to our friend andre sims
who composed his own rendition of few
elise
and mixed it with his jazzy style to
create something completely new and
surprising
can you explain why you chose fur elise
to make an arrangement out of it
what attracted you to it and
what the process was like as a teacher i
was like okay well i hear this song so
much even when i heard other teachers
teaching from other rooms
for example it was just becoming
like externally exhausting to hear i did
this in a live show
at a jazz show and it was on the wing
like we didn't practice it
after the show it was like everybody
like gave me a standing ovation like
all the bad songs we did that night was
like great great but that one song
people was asking me like
over and over again after the show hey
where can we hear that at you know like
where where's this at is this on itunes
i'm like
no it's just uh this is the way that i
can cope with my students
[Laughter]
you guys hear this good yeah i can hear
it i'ma play the way i started off and
like i said in the show so
[Music]
like
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so by now you hopefully have a better
idea of why fair elise has become one of
the most famous classical pieces
in the world when it comes to whether or
not it's overrated
well that depends on who you ask to some
it's way too overplayed but to others
it's their favorite piece to perform
what's more important is that furley's
has somehow now become a permanent part
of our culture
ah awesome awesome awesome amazing
amazing
amazing have you ever wondered what
makes words
well words other words
pbs's newest show on language and
linguistics has you covered
from determining the origins of language
to whether or not computers can actually
talk
other words dives into languages around
the world to
uncover the fascinating unexpected and
sometimes weird stories behind the human
trait
we all take for granted check it out on
story
and be sure to let them know that
soundfield's sent you and a huge shout
out to the clyburn
whose mission is to advance classical
piano music throughout the world
for partnering with us on this video